france's new foreign minister katharine
colonna began her visit to ukraine by
paying her respects to the dead in bucha
ukrainians describe what happened to
civilians at the hands of russian forces
as war crimes
we must tell ourselves that this should
never have happened here and it
shouldn't happen again
france stands with its friends its
allies to do whatever possible to bring
back peace
support and solidarity likely to help
paris reset relations with kiev
ukraine has accused france of siding
with russia
as the war carries on the hope is french
diplomacy with moscow will help ease
russia's blockade of ukrainian ports and
restart the export of ukrainian crops
vital to the global food supply
but that is not all ukraine means
i have stressed today during the meeting
that ukraine's need of additional
artillery systems of 155 caliber remains
extremely important to win the battle
for donbass we need to significantly
strengthen our artillery potential
a clear message from kelowna's
counterpart ukrainians who have been
paying the price for russian aggression
in lives for years
need more help
her trip was underlined by a cruel
coincidence the brutality of the war
brought closer to home with the death of
a french journalist covering the war
frederick le clerc imhoff from bfm tv
was killed by shelling in the luhansk
region while accompanying an armored
mission to evacuate civilians
colonel called for an investigation into
his death
the number of journalists killed
covering the war now stands at 24.
war in towns and villages in the east
and south has become a patchwork of
fighting the spotlight is currently on
sevra donetsk one of two cities in the
luhansk region still barely under
ukrainian control
the russian siege of this city has come
at a high price in lives and military
assets on both sides
weapons and ammunition left behind on
the battlefield this russian soldier
says are from ukraine's western allies
even as they collect trophies and
conquer territory what they consider
decisive battles may not be over france
is sending ukraine more help
during her visit the french foreign
minister said that her government will
be committing more essential equipment
to ukraine
fire trucks and ambulances to help cope
with the near daily bombardment of
russia's villages towns and cities but
more crucially heavy artillery
long-range howitzers that it is hoped
will help turn the tide of this war in
ukraine's favor
zain basravi al-jazeera kiev